who do you think you are
don't you think 35 million dollars is
too much for a center
and don't you know you can't save
everybody
[Music]
hello everybody my name is pastor corey
brooks and you got it i'm still here
that's right on top of this roof on the
south side of chicago
living out of this tent for 100 days
from november the 20th till february
28th bringing attention and awareness to
the violence that we deal with every
single day on the south side of chicago
but also talking about the solutions and
ideas
rooftop revelations we're trying to
build a community center that costs
upward of 35 million dollars and we're
going to do it
every now and then i get to bring you
because of fox
these ideas these solutions these
thoughts
and sometimes when i wake up i just wake
up with a thought or an idea and i want
to share with my rooftop family my fox
family of rooftop revelation is what i
call it
and today
i got a thought
from
an email
and the email our summizer just
basically went something like this
who do you think you are
don't you think 35 million dollars is
too much for a center and don't you know
you can't save everybody
and i realized at that moment
everybody isn't for you
everybody isn't going to cheer for you
everybody isn't going to applaud you
there are going to be times when people
are just outright haters
and they don't want the best for you or
the community
and you can let that stop you or you can
let it motivate you
as soon as i read that
email i was a little downtrodden until i
remembered a story
about an old man who was walking along
the seashore and all of these starfish
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
had washed up on the shore and this old
man was walking down the seashore
picking them up one at a time
throwing them back in the sea
picking them up one at a time
throwing them back in the sea
this person saw him doing and they said
who do you think you are you're a stupid
old man what do you think you're doing
all of those starfishes walked have
washed up on the uh on the on the shore
and who do you think you are you can't
save all those starfish
and the old man
looked at him and said you know what
you're right
but at least
[Music]
i can save this one
and that's kind of how i feel about it
we may not be able to save everybody on
the south side of chicago
we may not be able to impact everyone's
life
but there are some people that we're
going to reach
there are some lives that are going to
be changed
and even if it's just that one little
boy who's without a father
that one little boy
who's looking for guidance
even if it's just that one little girl
whose mom
has been lost in the world and
she finds herself trouble trying to find
her way
we'll save just that one
that's just my rooftop revelations for
today
like i always say
peace
you